[Musik]
ausgetrickt
Ampel ohne Geld und Zukunft Fragezeichen
das ist unser Thema heute einen guten
Abend liebe Zuschauer das Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts hat der Ampel
den Boden unter den Füßen weggezogen
viele Milliarden die sie fest verplant
hatte fehlen plötzlich sie fehlen den
Bürgern den Unternehmen aber vor allen
fehlen sie der Ampel denn ihre Pläne
waren nur mit viel Geld unter einen Hut
zu bringen was wird aus dieser Regierung
wenn das Geld jetzt fehlt ist die
Schuldenbremse an allem schuld oder sind
es die Politiker die geglaubt haben sie
austrexen zu können heute erklärt nun
Christian Lindner das Jahr
2023 nachträglich zu einem weiteren
notlagenjahr ein bisschen spät könnte
man sagen und hat das größte Problem
aber noch vor sich wir müssen reden mit
diesen Gästen der Fraktionsvorsitzende
der FDP
christianer Chef der CS Landesgruppe im
Bundestag der grüne Finanzminister von
badenwürtemberg Danial
bayas die Wirtschaftsweise Monika
Schnitzer dagma Rosenfeld
Chefredakteurin der Welt am
Sonntag und die ZDF Rechtsexpertin Sarah
Tacke sie sind zu Gast bei Maybritt
ilner und die begrüßt alle Gäste noch
mal ausgesprochen herzlich die Ampel war
gestartet mit vielen Ideen und mit viel
Geld und dann kam etwas
dazwischen sie wollten Großes schaffen
die selbsternannten
fortschrittskoalitionäre sogar scheinbar
Gegensätzliches verbinden Schuldenbremse
einhalten und gleichzeitig viel Geld
ausgeben fürs Ziel Klimaneutralität der
Trick nicht ausgezahlte coronahilfen
einfach auch als wirtschaftsbooster für
die Zukunft benutzen freute sich das
Finanzministerium damals wir schlagen
vor die bereits im letzten Jahr von der
Vorgängerregierung erfolgte Zuweisung um
weitere 60 Milliarden Euro zu ergänzen
er gilt als Erfinder der trixerei nach
Ausbruch des ukrainekrieges setzt auch
der Kanzler auf Finanzierung fern ab vom
Haushalt um horende Gas und Strompreise
zu drücken man kann sagen dass es hier
ein
doppelums ein Jahr später hat es sich
ausgetrix das des Verfassungsgerichts
ein ganz anderer Wums als erhofft wobei
die Tragweite der Ampel schon vorher
klar war wenn diese Klage erfolgreich
ist das würde Deutschland wirklich
wirtschaftspolitisch hart hart treffen
wahrscheinlich so hart dass wir das
nicht bestehen werden jetzt steht vieles
zur Disposition
bahnsanierung industriewwandel
energiepreisbremse für den laufenden
Haushalt will Christian Lindner nun doch
die Schuldenbremse aussetzen die
Beratungen fürs kommende Jahr liegen auf
Eis Christian D Fraktionsvorsitzender
der FDP Schuldenbremse jetzt plötzlich
doch aussetzen wie macht der
Finanzminister das er muss die Notlage
erklären und dann also es geht jetzt um
einen Nachtragshaushalt 2023 das hat der
Finanzminister heute erklärt und das
auch richtig als Reaktion auf dieses
Urteil denn Frau ilner das Urteil hat ja
zwei wesentliche Merkmale der erste das
erste Merkmal ist dass Kredite die
genehmigt worden sind in der
Vergangenheit aber nicht ausgegeben
worden sind in andere Jahre nicht
übertragen werden Düren genau und zum
zweiten es muss ein direkter
Sachzusammenhang da sein das heißt wenn
eine Notlage erklärt wird dann muss der
Sachzusammenhang klar sein und dieser
sachzus dieser Sachzusammenhang ist da
aber es ist sozusagen die Notlage im
falschen Jahr erklärt worden deswegen
holen wir das jetzt nach das ist eine
Praxis die wir aus den Ländern kennen
die der Bund auch früher schon gemacht
hat und wir beenden das jetzt nach dem
Urteil des Verfassungsgerichts es gehört
sich so dass man sich dran hält was das
Gericht Urteil früher schon gemacht hat
gestern wollte ich fragen also um nicht
zu sagen vorgestern hat die FDP hat der
Bundesfinanzminister ja gesagt dass sie
sich über dieses Urteil freuen dass sie
dankbar sind dafür dass es so gekommen
ist dass die Krise im Grunde zu Beginn
des Jahres 23 vorbei war ist auch
formuliert worden das gilt nun alles
nicht mehr nein es gibt jetzt in der
Sache Klarheit und wichtig ist eins auch
im Bezug auf den Beschluss der jetzt
ansteht im im Deutschen Bundestag für
den Haushalt 2023 es geht nicht darum
zusätzlich Kredite zu genehmigen oder
zusätzliches Geld auszugeben das heißt
die Verschuldung erhöht sich dadurch
nicht ohnehin bei dieser Debatte muss
man auch zwei Dinge
unterscheiden ja ich doch ich will das
ganz kurz sagen fr inner einerseits die
Frage welche buchungen sind da die
Praxis beenden wir jetzt und
andererseits die Frage wie viel Schulden
macht der Bund in Wirklichkeit und was
diese Koalition gemeinsam geschaffen hat
wir haben die Schuldenquote nach unten
gebracht von kN 70% deutlich runter und
darum geht's ja wie steht der Bund in
der Kreide das ist glücklicherweise
zurück zurückgegangen die Buchung gleich
wohl die müssen sich ändern und jetzt
hören wir die anderen tollen Gäste
dieser Sendung dass sie erstmal einen
traurigen Umstand erklären wollten und
sollten muss geschehen dagma Rosenfeld
ist bei uns Chefredakteurin der Welt am
Sonntag Vau Rosenfeld die FDP wollte
patun nicht der Bundesfinanzminister
wollte patun nicht ein weiteres Mal
diese Schuldenbremse aussetzen sonst
hätte er es ja im Januar des Jahres 23
getan wie kommt man da jetzt mit einer
guten Begründung die Ecke na der
Bundesfinanzminister hat heute gesagt er
würde reinen Tisch machen indem er jetzt
eben einen Nachtragshaushalt den Entwurf
wird der nächste Woche Vorlesen legen
für 2023 er hat es vermieden das Wort
Schuldenbremse in den Mund zu nehmen ähm
und ich finde nicht dass er reinen Tisch
macht sondern auf den schmutzigen Tisch
wird eine frische Tischdecke einfach
drüber gelegt und ähm was heute klar
geworden ist der Ampelkoalition ist es
nicht gelungen das selbstgesetzte Ziel
die Schuldenbremse in diesem Jahr
einzuhalten auch zu vollbringen und
deswegen wird jetzt eine Notlage
ausgerufen im Nachhinein und dann sind
wir Monika Schnitzer Ökonomen
Wirtschaftsweise also in diesem
erlauchten Kreis der regelmäßig
einschätzt wie es der deutschen
Volkswirtschaft eigentlich geht bei
welcher Dimension nur um das noch mal zu
verstehen wir reden nicht mehr nur über
diesen
klimatransformationsfond der nichtig
erklärt wurde in seiner Umbuchung
sondern auch über den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungs Fond wir
reden über 40 Milliarden in 23 haben wir
heute verstanden und reden dann auch
über diesen doppelwums aus insgesamt 200
Milliarden das heißt wie viel Geld ist
plötzlich nicht mehr da wir müssen da
wirklich zwei Dimensionen sehen das ist
einmal genau die finanzielle Dimension
der KTF dieser klimatransformationsfond
da hatte ja 60 Milliarden zurückgelegt
um ausgegeben zu werden und aus diesem
Wirtschafts stabilisierungsfond waren
noch 160 Milliarden übrig aus dem
letzten Jahr die kann man eben jetzt
auch nicht mehr so verteilen und wenn
das jetzt zusammengerechnet wird dann
sind wir schon bei einem halben
Bundeshaushalt das ist also schon eine
gewaltige finanzielle Dimension ich will
aber noch die zweite Dimension nennen
das ist die psychologische Dimension wir
haben jetzt Klarheit in der Sache
Rechtsklarheit das stimmt aber wir haben
eine enorme Verunsicherung der
Wirtschaft und der Bevölkerung und jeder
der sich mit Wirtschaft auskennt weiß
das st die Wirtschaft das bremst die
Investitionsneigung das bremst die
Konsumlaune und deswegen wird es ganz
wichtig sein dass man sich jetzt schnell
zusammensetzt dass sich die Betroffenen
nicht nur in der Ampel sondern auch die
anderen Parteien dazus setzen und man
sich schnell überlegt wie kommt man aus
der Nummer raus denn das erwartet die
Bevölkerung kann man so sagen würde
Alexander dobrin wahrscheinlich sagen
einer der Oppositionsführer im Deutschen
Bundestag bleiben wir erstmal bei der
Sache die heute geschehen ist es wird
eine Schuldenbremse ein weiteres Mal
ausgesetzt werden sie wieder dagegen
klagen na erstmal kriegen wir wenn ja
dann überhaupt nur Klarheit für 2023 und
noch gar nicht für 2024 noch gar nicht
was da kommt noch einiges auf zu komm
noch daz wir die eigentliche
Schwierigkeit ja zweitens ist es ja
jetzt das Eingeständnis dass man ganz
offensichtlich einen Plan hatte nämlich
die Notlage nicht auszurufen dass man
die Schuldenbremse ganz offensichtlich
betrügen wollte das war die Idee und das
ist jetzt das Eingeständnis jetzt muss
man es machen weil man keine andere Idee
mehr hat vorher wollte man einfach durch
Tricksereien durch Betrug es
verschleiern wollte den Sack voll Geld
in den Keller stellen des
Finanzministeriums es ist eigentlich ein
Sack voll Schulden immer gewesen nie
Geld es war der Sack voll Schulden man
wollte sie zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt
egal für was egal für wann einfach
verwenden und den Leuten erklären schaut
mal wir halten die Schuldenbremse ein
das war der Versuch dieses Betruges so
das ist jetzt aufgedeckt das ist jetzt
klar das liegt jetzt mal auf dem Tisch
und jetzt geht's darum wie geht man
damit um jetzt muss man das auch rechts
sicher machen ob das jetzt möglich ist
das wird die Ampel uns erklären ich weiß
noch nicht wie man das tut ein
Gerichtsurteil alleine reicht sicherlich
als Begründung nicht aus dafür dass man
jetzt eine Notlage erklärt man wird das
schon sehr gut erklären müssen das
Verfassungsgericht das
Verfassungsgericht hat durchaus dem
Gesetzgeber doch relativ große
Spielräume eingeräumt aber er muss sie
halt jetzt auch richtig nutzen wir
werden uns das im Detail anschauen wir
sind schon konstruktiv im Sinne von wir
wollen jetzt der Ampel nicht noch
zusätzliche Schwierigkeiten machen mehr
als sie sich selber schon gemacht hat
aber wir werden darauf achten dass es
rechtskonform ist und dass nicht ein
weiterer Betrug oder das nicht weitere
Versuche die Verfassung zu brechen mit
dem nächsten Haushalt schon
vorprogrammiert ich würde nur ganz kurz
prognostizieren dass die Union nicht
klagen wird gegen die Ausrufung der
Notlage weil das was auf Bundesebene
jetzt passieren wird passiert auch
gerade in Bundesländern die
unionsgeführt sind also in
schleswig-holtstein ist nachträglich
auch für 2023 die Notlage ausgerufen
worden für 2024 wohl auch Nord
reinwestfahen wird geprüft also dieses
Urteil stellt eben grundsätzlich eine
Finanzierungsmethode in Frage oder
verbietet sie die nicht nur eine Methode
der Ampel gewesen aber do es geht ja nur
darum es muss am Schluss rechtskonform
sein das das was ich haben wir
hingewiesen das muss
funktionieren stimmt es stimmt nicht
dass die vergangenen Regierung so
gehandelt
hesag kom gleich draf zurück wir begrüen
erstmisüßen erstm der Finanzminister im
schönen länle ist in badenwürttberg
nämlich in einer grünschwarzen Regierung
herras wir haben jetzt über Christian
lind gesprochen über die Situation der
Ampel gesprochen wie sehr trifft das die
Grünen wie sehr trifft das
nicht wie sehr trifft das jetzt nicht
nur den Finanzminister der ein völlig
kontreres eine völlig konträre
Entscheidung gefällt hat wie sehr trifft
es Robert habck ich glaube die Situation
ist so ernst dass Parteipolitik
zumindest nicht in erster Linie
angebracht ist und nehmen wir den
klimatransformationsfond das ist jetzt
nicht die Spielzeugkiste vom
Bundeswirtschaftsminister sondern da
geht es um wichtige Projekte wie
Stahlproduktion in nordreheinwest fahen
wie Batteriezellen in Schleswig-Holstein
wie wasserstoffprojekte in
Baden-Württemberg oder Halbleiter in
Magdeburg da geht's um die Zukunft des
Wirtschafts und
Industriestandortes haben Sie sich schon
gefragt der also Herr habbeck tut das
natürlich wenn auch nur indirekt wie
konnte das
passieren er hat indirekt formuliert
dass er sich nicht so richtig daran
erinnern kann wessen Idee das eigentlich
war zurückgt diese umbuchungsidee auf
Olaf Scholz den damaligen fin
Finanzminister offensichtlich hat
Christian Lindner irgendwann
eingeschlagen fragen Sie sich auch wie
sowas passieren kann ich hatte da immer
ein mulmiges Gefühl also zunächst einmal
das sind wirklich zwei Aspekte das eine
ist die buchungssystematik über Jahre da
hat der Christian dür völlig recht wenn
jetzt nachträglich die Notlage erklärt
wird fließt deswegen nicht mehr oder
weniger Geld ab materiell macht es
keinen Unterschied die Umbuchung von
Krediten da kann man auch als
Nichtjuristen mulmiges Gefühl haben ob
das so richtig ist ja und ich glaube da
hat diese Bundes Regierung jetzt
leerrgeld bezahlt das hätte man
sicherlich anders machen können aber
wissen Sie diese negative Fehlerkultur
wer ist schuld wessen Kopf muss Rollen
die bringt uns in der Situation nicht
weiter sondern ich glaube die Frage ist
und das wirklich es geht um die Zukunft
des Wirtschafts und Industriestandortes
wie kommen wir da raus das ist die
zentrale Frage und darüber müssen wir
sprechen so und dann sitzt mit Christian
D aber jemand neben ihnen der Kollegen
im Stuttgarter Landtag hat die Kollegen
Parteifreunde von Christian D drohen
jetzt ihnen dem Finanzminister von
badenwürttenemberg gerade mit einer
Klage weil auch sie prüfen müssen ob sie
coronahilfen in andere Jahre gebucht
haben die Kollegen aus dem Landtag der
FDP haben schon mal geklagt sind damit
gescheitert wir
haben und deswegen ich glaube jeder in
der Runde wir haben paar schon Töne
gehört der mit dem Finger auf jemand
zeigt zeigt gleichzeitig malmer auf
seinen eigenen Laden weil hier wird die
Haushaltssystematik in Bund und Ländern
im Fundament berührt es ist so dass wir
uns das Urteil sehr genau anschauen was
ich sagen kann für mein Land Württemberg
wir haben da stand mein
Ministerpräsident da stand ich
persönlich im Wort nie coronakredite
umgebucht wir haben coronakredite die
wir nicht genutzt haben auch getilt also
Schulden zurückgeführt und trotzdem geht
es auch an die grundsätzliche Systematik
der Haushaltsführung deswegen werden wir
uns das genau anschauen aber das was die
Bundesregierung jetzt gemacht hat
nämlich Kredite umgewidmet haben wir in
den Ländern nicht gemacht in anderen
Ländern war das der Fall wir sind da
unterinander im Austausch und das ist
der Beginn einer großen
finanzpolitischen Diskussion weil was
wir gerade erleben ist eine
finanzpolitische Zeitenwende wir hab
okay wir sind trotzdem beim Klären noch
mal eines Faktes und zwar an Frau
Schnitzer und an Herrn säßen wir in
dieser Situation Frau Schmitzer wenn
sowohl für das Jahr 2023 als auch für
das Jahr 2024 rechtzeitig genug von der
Ampel eine Notlage erklärt worden wäre
wir hätten dann auf jeden Fall nicht das
dilemmer was wir jetzt haben die Frage
wäre nur mit welcher Notlage hätte man
jetzt die Finanzen in dieser Höhe
begründen können ich frage jetzt
unbedingt hern ist die Situation in der
die Regierung jetzt sitzt ist die
Patsche in der diese diese Regierung
jetzt sitzt der Entscheidung zu danken
im Januar des Jahres 2023 nicht die
Notlage erklärt zu haben dieser
Mechanismus betrifft diese genannten
Sondervermögen nicht den Bundeshaushalt
insgesamt denn sie haben vollkommen
recht man kann die Notlage das sagte ich
vor ein Eingang schon Frau ilner nicht
einfach fröhlich ausrufen sondern es
braucht dringend den Sachzusammenhang
auch das hat das Verfassungsgericht
klargestellt
und und wir haben wir tun das diese
Situation jetzt nicht genau wir tun das
im Bezug auf ein Saag zu nein lass kurz
ausführen auf einen Sachzusammenhang der
gegegen ist nämlich die
energiepreisbremsen also Strum und
gaspreisbremsen da war ein energieschock
ein Preisschock zu dem Zeitpunkt und
diese und diese Begründung wird jetzt
ganz genau nachgeliefert für genau diese
Verausgabung die bereits getätigt worden
sind wichtig ist ja ein zuwissen die 60
Milliarden über die oft geredet wird von
denen ist zum Glück kein Cent ausgegeben
worden da ist kein wirtschaftlicher
Schaden dan B sagte das gerade
entstanden sondern es geht jetzt darum
dass das was veranschlagt worden ist
eben eine Notsituation war und ich
glaube bei den energieshoocks ist es
jeben klar die preisbremsen waren
sinnvoll da gibt's glaube ich auch gar
keine Kritik das war Ende des Jahres
schon klar genau deswegen haben wir in
unserem Gutachten ja auch schon
reingeschrieben aus transparenzgründen
wäre es sinnvoll gewesen eben zu sagen
diese Energiekrise wirkt noch 20 wir
brauchen dafür noch die hil und das
hätte man damals schon so reinschreiben
können es war also nicht besonders
transparent was man gemacht warum hat
man es damals nicht gemacht ist ja die
große Frage ich will genau darauf noch
mal hinaus weil ja auch Alexander Duben
vor freundlich nachgefragt hat
freundlich nachgefragt hat dass jetzt
hier etwas sei was früher nicht der Fall
gewesen ist man h ja ganz ich
komm warum wollte Christian Lindner
nicht die Notlage weil die bisherige
Praxis so war es war eine beschlossene
Notlage für das Jahr 2022 das war der
Angriffskrieg Russlands auf die Ukraine
der diesen energiepreisock in Europa
ausgelö hat g genau und dann haben wir
gesagt wie bisherige Staatspraxis dafür
ist die Notlage bereits beschlossen also
geht sie auch in den Folgejahren die
Union hat beispielsweise in ihrer
Regierungsverantwortung damals noch mit
dieser Praxis nachvollziehbar für die
Flutopfer im Atal ein Sondervermögen
gebildet und Kredite aufgenommen und den
notfallmechanismus ausgelöst der
Schuldenbremse und diese Kredite dann in
die Folgejahre übertragen auch dafür
müssen wir jetzt den notfallmechanismus
noch mal nachziehen denn eins ist doch
klar die Opfer müssen das Geld auf jeden
Fall bekommen aber diesen mechan Herr
dobr das muss man aller Klarheit sagen
und es wäre merkwünndig wenn sie
wiedersprechen würden weil das im
Bundesgesetz steht diesen Mechanismus
der Beladung von Sondervermögen mit
Krediten auch für die Folgejahre für die
die Bremse jetzt dann eben nicht mehr
gilt nach dem Urteil genau diesen
Mechanismus hat der Bund früher auch
gemacht in der Vorgängerregierung und
ich sage selbstkritisch Frau ilner wir
hätten mit dieser Praxis früher Schluss
machen müssen jetzt machen wir mit
dieser praxiss Schluss das gilt für
dieses Teil des Sondervermögens auch für
die Strom und
Gaspreis mus aber wier sprechen weil er
ja einen wesentlichen Punkt ich wollte
ganz kurz noch mal einen einen fast
frischen Christian Lindner zitieren aber
dann sind sie doort das Vorgehen haben
wir als rechtlich verantwortbar
eingeschätzt weil auch die CDU geführte
Vorgängerregierung
2020 schon einmal 26 Milliarden Euro in
den Fond überführt
hatte begründete Christian Lindner noch
am letzten Wochenende sie finden das
eine Frechheit immer noch oder schließen
Sie sich der Argumentation von Herr D
nein es ist einfach falsch was Herr D
sagt weil er ganz einen wesentlichen
Unterschied versucht einfach zu
verschweigen oder er vergisst ihn an
dieser Stelle das was diese Regierung
gemacht hat ist dass sie diese neuen
Schulden auf alte Jahre gebucht hat das
dient ja dieser Verschleierung und das
ist einmalig das hat es halt noch nie
gegeben und das ist ja auch im Urteil
des Verfassungsgericht eindeutig auch so
kritisiert und kann ja auch noch keine
Notlage gegeben haben weil g die Notlage
die Notlage war damals ja schon gr die
Notlage hat es damals gegeben aus
coronagründen und deswegen war es ja so
verlockend aus der Sicht der Ampel zu
sagen lasst uns neue Schulden in alte
Jahre buchen und das Geld deutlich
später zu verwenden grö die
Größenordnung g ist mit dem
Nachtragshaushalt diese buchungspraxis
geändert worden also die Tatsache dass
man sagt alle Schulden die wir jetzt
aufnehmen die buchen wir auf 2022 wir
Bremsen wir reisen einmal im großen Stil
die Schuldenbremse und danach halt en
wir Sie ein das ist mit dem
Nachtragshaushalt damals eingeführt
worden die buchungspraxis war vorher
anders und das ist die Antwort auf die
Frage warum Anfang dieses Jahres keine
Notlage erklärt weil man es politisch
schlichtweg nicht wollte es gab eine
Vereinbarung innerhalb der Ampel die SBD
kriegt ihre Sozialprojekte die Grünen
kriegen ihre Klimaprojekte und die FDP
die kriegt das Einhalten der
Schuldenbremse und keine Steuererhöhung
das war der Grund warum man dann am
Schluss zu dieser tricksere gekommen sie
ver sie verschleiern ich will es mal in
aller Klarheit sagen Frau Öner ich habe
das Glück gehabt in der letzten
Wahlperiode auch im Haushaltsausschuss
zu sitzen ich habe an diesen
Bereinigungssitzung seiner Zeit
teilgenommen große Freude auch damals da
kam dann des Nachts übrigens
oppositionsrechte wurden übersichtlich
beachtet aber dar will ich mich gar
nicht beschweren da kam des Nachts dann
riesige Vorlagen 60 Milliarden neue
Schulden was sie dort unter anderem
gemacht haben weil ich vorhin gesagt
hate das Verfassungsgericht hat etwas
ganz ganz wichtiges auch festgestellt es
muss ein Sachzusammenhang gegeben sein
damals ist beispielsweise Kredite
Notkredite aufgenommen worden für den
Schutz des deutschen Waldes für den
stallumbau das mag alles sinnvolle
Projekte sein für eine
Klimaschutzinitiative aber hatte das was
mit Corona zu tun heute wissen wir nach
diesem Urteil das war definitiv
verfassungswidrig und deswegen beenden
wir jetzt diese Praxis her Dobrind aber
öffentlich zu behaupten die Union hätte
in eigener Verantwortung in der großen
Koalition so etwas nicht gemacht ist
einfach falsch Herr sie tun ja gerade so
als seien sie jetzt dem übertriebenen
Schutz der Schuldenbremse überführt
nein sie sind dem Bruch der Verfassung
überführt worden und dem Betrug der
Schuldenbremse versuchen Sie das mal
anzuerkennen ich habe selbsttisch gesagt
wir hätten die Praxis früher beenden
sollen vollkommen richtig jetzt beenden
wir diese
praxisosenfeld gäbe es diese ampe
überhaupt gäbe es diese Regierung
überhaupt wenn es die 60 Milliarden aus
dem KTF nicht aus diesem
klimatransformationsfond nicht gegeben
hätte wenn es den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond nicht
gäbe wird diese Ampel durch Geld
zusammengehalten ja also es ist noch
anders die Ampel wird dadurch
zusammengehalten dass sie Geld ausgibt
und so tut als ob sie kein Geld ausgeben
würde und
da geht dann zusammen einmal die
Erzählung der Grünen warum sie diese
Koalition mittragen ist ähm dass man den
Transformationsprozess hin zu einer
klimaneutralen Gesellschaft quasi zum
Nulltarif bekommt und man hat sich dort
die Grünen haben sozusagen die
Subventionen dafür bekommen und die FDP
hat die Schuldenbremse konnte sich als
Stabilitätsanker der finanzpolitischen
Vernunft generieren weil man im
knhaushalt die Schuldenbremse
tatsächlich eingehalten hat aber überb
Schattenhaushalte dann Schulden gemacht
hat und diese Praxis ist jetzt an ihr
Ende gekommen und ich glaube das
bedeutet für die Ampel tatsächlich dass
sie sich ein Stück weit neu erfinden
muss und sie wird klären müssen wie sie
ihre Klimapolitik was Sie für eine
Klimapolitik machen will und wie sie die
finanzieren will das wir die große
aufgab haben sie jetzt ausgelassen die
Sozialdemokratie wollte in alldem
natürlich nicht nur Respekt für die
Arbeitnehmer und ein großes
Sozialprojekt die Sozialdemokratie bekam
sehr schnell ihren Mindestlohn aber der
Kanzler war ist ja gleichzeitig
klimakanzler und gleichzeitig auch warer
der Schuldenbremse da sind Lindner und
Scholz ja immer Seite an Seite
geschritten wenn es darum ging die
Schuldenbremse einzuhalten die Grünen
haben ja sehr früh gesagt lasst uns die
Schuldenbremse aussetzen sie ist nicht
zeitgemäß lasst sie reformieren da gab
es dann doch den Schulterschluss
zwischen SPD und FDP aber die SPD bekam
das Bürgergeld was jetzt demnächst 10
Milliarden mehr kostet ja aber bleiben
wir noch mal bei der Frage was diese
chnungsmethode aus ihrer Regierungszeit
aber das weil wir noch mal verstehen
wollen dass man im Grunde grundsätzliche
Auseinandersetzungen nicht ausgetragen
hat sondern sie vorträglich mit viel
genau eigentlich hätten beide den
Koalition oder in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen die
Auseinandersetzung darüber ausgetragen
werden müssen wie wird die Klimapolitik
finanziert wird sie über Subventionen
gehen wie können wir die Schuldenbremse
einhalten wenn wir die Schuldenbremse
machen auf was wird verzichtet und diese
Debatte hat haben alle drei Parteien
nicht geführt weil es die geniale Idee
gab es gibt diesen Klima und
transformationsfond da Topfen wir die 60
Milliarden Euro krediterm die für Corona
nicht genutzt worden sind um und damit
bekamen die Grünen die Mittel für die
Klimapolitik die sie wollten und die FDP
konnte eben die Schuldenbremse waren und
diese Auseinandersetzung steht der Ampel
aber jetzt bevor man kann aber noch
böser Fragen Frau Rosenfeld man kann
Herr bajas noch böser fragen wie soll
diese Koalition zusammenhalten wenn
plötzlich kein Geld mehr da ist ich
würde ich bin bei ihnen was was sie
sagen und gleichzei einen Schritt
zurückgehen Koalitionen wurden immer ein
Stück weit von Geld zusammengehalten die
große Koalition hat es praktiziert indem
sie Kompromisse mit Prestigeprojekten
wie die mütterrente die Rente mit 63
zusammengekleistert hat ich sag das
jetzt mal so flapppsig aber wir waren da
in der anderen Welt seit der großen
Finanzmarktkrise kannte die
Steuereinnahmen nur eine Richtungen
jeder Finanzminister in Bund und Ländern
egal welches Parteibuch konnte sich die
schwarze Null ans reverheften aber er
musste halt nichts dafür so tun weil die
Steuereinnahmen diese Situation ergeben
haben dann kam hab die Pandemie 2020
Schuldenbremse wurde ausgesetzt der
Staat hat Geld auf alles geschüttet
vieles berechtigt und sicherlich hier
und da auch nicht ganz so klug
eingesetzt in der Rückschau ist man
immer schlauer und in dieser Phase kommt
eine neue Regierung ins Amt die einen
sagen hände weg von der Schuldenbremse
hände weg von der Steuerschraube
gleichzeitig wollen wir gestalten und
investieren und die Aufgaben werden ja
größer nicht kleiner und das ist die
wichtige das ist die die Frage wir haben
jetzt eine Lösung heute vom
Bundesfinanzminister
endlich auch vermittelt bekommen wie wir
das Jahr 23
bewerkstelligen ich glaube so viel
andere Alternativen hätte es nicht
gegeben wir werden sicherlich jetzt
gleich über das nächste Jahr sprechen
werden der Bundeshaushalt und ich will
noch eines sagen es ist auch ein
stückweites Ergebnis das nicht ehrlich
maens weil zu glauben wir kriegen eine
Transformation Energieversorgung
Investition in den Zukunftsstandort
Ausrüstung der Bundeswehr die wir ja
auch aus dem Sondervermögen finanzieren
was machen wir eigentlich wenn das
Sondervermögen mal leer ist und das
jetzt bei steigenden Zinsen das ist die
Quadrat des Kreises und ich glaube da
muss jede Partei die in der Regierung
sitzt ein Stück weit über ihren Schatten
springen weil Herr dobrin ich weiß es
nicht sie werden ja vielleicht auch mal
wieder anstreben in einer
Bundesregierung zu setzen ich gebe ein
Brief und Siegel wenn der
Bundesfinanzminister z.B mal Alexander
dobrin heißen sollte und der schaut in
die Kasse und sagt ich will auch dieses
ambitionierte Programm umsetzen und ich
glaube das sollte uns schuldig sein der
wird die gleichen Herausforderung die
gleichen Probleme haben wir
die fragen wir noch mal sie die FDP
freut sich über dieses Urteil zur
Schuldenbremse sie freute sich darüber
und fand dass es eine Stärkung der Idee
der Schuldenbremse gibt um den Preis
dass wichtige Projekte der Ampel jetzt
in Trümmern liegen Herrn B also dieser
Regierung hätte mal wirklich zugestanden
einfach zu sagen unsere Strategie ist
gescheitert positive Fehlerkultur und da
muss man der CDU Respekt sollen die
hatten den richtigen Riecher die haben
geklagt die haben das durchgezogen das
gehört in der Demokratie dazu die muss
man aber auch ihre staatspolitische
Verantwortung nach vorne gerichtet
erinnern und jetzt geht es darum glaube
ich mit unterschiedlichen Maßnahmen wie
können wir besser priorisieren wie
können wir auch die einnahmite Stärken
Stichwort CO2 Preis trauen wir uns mal
an die ökologisch schädlichen
Subventionen ran ich glaube da ist jeder
gefragt über seinen Schatten zu springen
um tragfähige Finanzen zu bekommen und
da ist der Bundesfinanzminister find die
schon in der Verantwortung auch einen
ausgeglichenen Vorschlag zu machen ähm
und das werden wir in der ampelregierung
sicherlich intensiv oder rufen Sie
einfach wieder eine Notlage aus für 24
äh ich sagte von das Verfassungsgericht
hat richtigerweise sehr enge Grenzen
gesetzt man kann nicht einfach eine
Notlage ausrufen es braucht ein sach
zusammen fragen wir gleich Frau
Schnitzer noch mal Frau Schnitzer ist
das tatsächlich in ihren Augen auch so
wir haben Flüchtlinge wir haben einen
Nahostkrieg wir haben immer noch eine
Energiekrise nicht mehr ganz so doll
aber wir haben eine Inflation wir haben
fällt uns noch was ein also kann man
nicht auch für 2024 eine Notlage
begründen
ja ich glaube da muss man wirklich über
zwei Dinge nachdenken erstens mal wel ja
welche Notlage und
braucht nicht tatsächlich Einnahmen also
ich find mit dem zweiten Punkt mal
anfangen das war ganz wichtig was her
Bayers eben sagte man muss jetzt mal so
ehrlich sein zu sagen wir haben eine
coronapandemie gehabt wir haben eine
Energiekrise gehabt wir haben momentan
geopolitische Spannungen all das kostet
Geld und wir können nicht so tun als ob
wir da ohne Kosten rauskommen und
irgendjemand muss die tragen kann man an
der Stelle schon mal drüber nachdenken
ob man das nicht auch dadurch trägt dass
man die Menschen die sich es leisten
können daran beteiligt an diesen Kosten
wir haben
energiepreisbremsen ausgezahlt für alle
die manche haben es nicht gebraucht aber
wir
konnten wir konnten sich Ziel genau
machen wir haben letztes Jahr schon
gesag Worte das war Quatsch in ihren
Augen hätte man nicht war schon in de
Moment Quatsch eine kisbremse wie wir
sie auch an anderen Stellen beim Strom
gemacht haben s hte tatsächlich im
letzten Jahr schon und das hatten wir
auch vorgeschlagen SAS wir ein
energiesoli einführen können um die
Menschen zu beteiligen die sich es
wirklich leisten wir sind Ihnen gefällt
es alles nicht das ist mir ich würde
einen Hinweis dazu geben wollen sie
wollen sagen dass sie jetzt ganz viel
sparen wollen in 2024 und dass man
nachholen muss was man in 21 nicht getan
hat die erste Analyse natürlich müssen
wir jetzt sparen wir müssen mit dem Geld
zurecht kommt was uns die Steuerzahler
und Steuerzahler zur Verfügung stellen
und ja nicht so dass Deutschland ein
niedrigsteuerland schon in der
Vergangenheit gewesen ist erst wir am
meisten
veren will g die Dinge ging ganz genau
hier gingen die Dinge ganz kurz aus
meiner Sicht durcheinander die eine
Frage ist wie erreichen wir die
Klimaschutzziele möglicherweise auch mit
Steuergeld auf der einen Seite auf der
anderen Seite haben wir aktuell eine
Notlage ich bin andere Auffassung als
Frau schn Finanz ich bin andere
Aufassung auch an der eigenen Praxis
absolut ich bin andere Auffassung als
Frau Schnitzer dass man jetzt einfach so
die Notlage ausrufen könnte und rate
davon ab aber die Frage ist wie schaffen
wir die Zukunft Investition und da ist
meine Antwort äh der Klima und
transformationsform der besteht mit
nichten aus diesen 60 Milliarden Euro
kreditermächtigung die nicht gezogen
worden sind und deshalb wenige Stunden
nach dem Urteil durch den Finanzminister
gelöscht worden sind aber er steht
besteht auch aus eigenen Einnahmen z.B
aus den CO2 Einnahmen das heißt da ist
durchaus der ist größer da ist durchaus
auch geldfand ich will einfach nur die
Sorge nehmen dass jetzt gar kein Geld
mehr da wäre für Aufgaben aber man muss
sich konzentrieren und priorisieren und
der zweite Teil Frau ner nicht alles
wird in der Transformation der Staat
machen können neun von 10 €os die in
Deutschland investiert werden kommen von
der Privatwirtschaft das ist der Grund
warum wir das Wachstum chancengesetz in
der Ampelkoalition gerade letzte Woche
durchgebracht haben nämlich mehr private
Investitionen auszulöen wir müssen ein
bisschen wegkommen von der denke dass
wir eine Art subventionswirtschaft
hätten und damit alles gestalten wir
haben eine soziale Marktwirtschaft
deswegen Rat ich dringend von
Steuererhöhung und nur subventions aber
gerade die Industrie fordert das doch
und sie stehen doch der Industrie
durchaus im also im guten Kontakt sagen
wir mal so und die Industrie hat die
ganze Zeit gefordert das ist unterstütz
die klimatransformation
FDP FDP die FDP ist keine pro Business
Partei für einzelne Unternehmen sondern
eine proarket Partei wir glauben an die
sozial eine kleine Kritik an Herr Scholz
heraus nein ich will damit in aller der
Herr Scholz war übrigens bei dem Thema
brückenstrompreis was ja eine ebliche
Subvention für nur wenige gewesen wä
hatte die gleiche gleiche Auffassung wie
die FDP will ich Schut für Intel
eingesetzt hat sich sehr
es alles gut man muss im Detail über
alles reden es gibt auch nicht nur
schwarz und weiß aber der Gedanke wir
könnten die Aufgaben beim Klimaschutz
nur durch Staatsknete lösen
istst ich
wollte der Eindruck in der
Öffentlichkeit entsteht dass der Staat
der einzige das ist genau das was ich
meinte wenn ich sag jeder muss über
seinen Schatten springen ich glaube also
wenn man das Bild größer macht privates
Kapital absolut auch etwas dem ich mE
Partei
immer prorisieren das sagt jeder
Finanzminister aus dem Ländler erst
recht gehört auch dazu drittens wir
schieben sogenannte ausgabereste vor uns
her weil die Gelder die wir zur
Verfügung stehen gar nicht so schnell
abfließen da müssen wir schneller werden
planungsbeschleibung Bürokratie Abbau
und das sind drei Hebel es kommt ein
vierter und die sind gleichberechtigt
und ich glaube die sind gleichberechtigt
müssen sie auch diskutiert werden die
Frage ob wir mit den Schuldenregeln wie
wir sie heute haben dauerhaft die
Aufgaben die wir leisten müssen so
bewerkstelligen wollen weil machen wir
mal zwei Schritte zurück wir haben
dreistellige Milliarden Beträge im Kampf
gegen die Krisen in die Hand genommen
und jetzt ist die Frage wer zahlt dafür
eigentlich die Rechnung und entweder und
Sie haben Recht ich glaube hohe
Steuererhöhung in dieser Situation ist
nicht die richtige Antwort aber nur im
Schulden machen kann auch nicht die
Antwort sein aber es muss doch irgendwas
dazwischen gehen und ich glaube die
Schuldenbremse und ich bin ich halte das
für eine Errungenschaft Schuldenbremse
eine Errungenschaft sie muss aber klüger
ausgestaltet werden um Investitionen zu
ermöglichen und ich glaube diese
Diskussion müssen wir uns auch führen
dann ich verstehe dass sie diese
Diskussion führen W ganz viele kluge
Menschen beklagen den jetzigen Zustand
der Schuldenbremse und da ist nahezu
unerheblich aus welcher Partei sie
kommen und trotzdem halten wir Herr D
hier ist die Seite der ampelregierung
noch mal ganz kurz fest Christian
Lindner ist wie die gesamte Regierung in
21 von verfassungsexperten gewarnt
worden diesen diese Umbuchung
vorzunehmen also in Geld aus einer
coronanotlage umzun nutzen keinst Plan
zu haben in dieser Situation keinen
worstc Plan zu haben und jetzt
anzufangen über diese Szenarien
nachzudenken ist das Dummheit ist es
Arroganz ist das
zahlässigkeit das Szenario lautet wir
setzen das um was das Verfassungsgericht
geurteilt hat wir machen nicht mehr
solche Dinge wie Corona Milliarden
ausgeben für alles mögliche wie gesagt
ich bin sehr für den deutschen Wald komm
aus dem ländlichen Raum aber was das mit
Corona zu tun hatte da ma ich schon
Fragezeichen die Frage noch Antwort die
Antwort Frau ist sehr klar der Plan ist
das Urteil nein das Urteil
umzusetzenagenen die Menschen in diesem
Land auf eine erkung sagen das Urteil
eins zu eins umzusetzen und gleichzeitig
das was beispielsweise im Klima und
transformationsform ist zu priorisieren
für echte Klimaschutzprojekte die auch
eine marktwirtschaftliche Dynamik haben
so dass war am Ende mehr
Wirtschaftswachstum draus haben eine
Priorisierung deswegen hat der
Finanzminister wie ich finde heute
zurecht gesagt wir werden auch Spen
müssen und auch darüber in der Koalition
reden das ist doch die richtige Reaktion
hören wir erstmal dem
Bundeswirtschaftsminister zu der auch
Vizekanzler ist und dann ist Herr dobrin
wieder dran Herr Habeck hat gedacht und
gesagt was er findet wer jetzt
eigentlich daran schuld ist wenn die
Leute weniger in der Tasche haben das
heißt aber im Klartext dass jedenfalls
für die Zukunft die Bürgerin und
bürgerhöher Strom und gegebenenfalls
Gaspreise bekommen werden also die
dankees schreiben die könnt die gleich
an die Union richten und Friedrich
merzich zustellen Dankes Schreiben an
die Union Friedrich März persönlich
zustellen wenn jetzt höhere Strom und
Gaspreise zu zahlen sind finden sie das
fair finden Sie es lauter das spricht
jetzt nicht dafür dass hab jetzt eine
Erkenntnis aus dem
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil gewonnen hat
nicht wir sind verklagt worden sondern
logischerweise ist die Ampel verklagt
worden weil sie einen Fehler gemacht hat
darauf Konten wir uns ja auch schon
verständigen und das ist auch was
staatspolitische Verantwortung angeht
wir sind doch nicht die klackure der
ampelregierung wir sind die Kontrolleure
der ampelregierung so und deswegen
weisen wir darauf hin wenn Fehler
passieren wenn staatspolitische
Verantwortung gefragt ist 100 Milliarden
für die Bundeswehr das ging nur mit uns
mit unserer Bereitschaft weil wir gesagt
haben ja diese Investitionen brauchen
wir dann machen wir die Verfassung
sicher indem wir sie separat ins
Grundgesetz reinschreiben das war mit
Zustimmung der Union möglich aber jetzt
steht wir ja vor einer großen
Herausforderung und habik hat die
anscheinend oder will sie ja
wahrscheinlich auch nicht erkennen 2024
hat die Ampel schlichtwig keinen Plan
weil die drei ampelmänner jeder hat ja
noch im Kopf als sie da standen nach dem
Urteil sie wussten überhaupt nicht über
was sie eigentlich reden sollen außer
der Tatsache dass sie sich an ein
Gerichtsurteil halten wollen kam da
nichts vom Bundeskanzler hört man
übrigens jetzt seit einer Woche gar
nichts also der führt ja dieses Land und
man hört nichts dazu was er machen will
was man hört ist Christian Lindner sagt
morgen in einer Zeitung ein
zweistelliger Milliardenbetrag soll
eingespart werden und am grünen
Parteitag da werden wir hören dass man
die Ausgaben eher noch ausweiten muss
für Klimaschutz oder ähnliches an dieser
Stelle das ist bisher nicht aufgelöst
und ich will mal eine Zahl weil das so
nett klingt wenn Herr Bayer sagt wir
müssen aber doch jetzt Investitionen
schaffen und alles richtig aber mit dem
Geld das wir haben wir haben einen
Haushalt von fast 500 Milliarden Euro
ein rekordhaushalt 20% höher als vor der
coronazeit
haben mein Argument zu Ende bringen das
ist
die ist das erstm die nackte
Zahl
mehr weil es einfach nominal höher ist
weil wir Inflation haben sie haben mehr
steuereinahen jetzt B wir mal dabei mein
Argument und dann können Sie darüber
urteilen die nackte Zahl ist es ist ein
rekordhaushalt fast 500 Milliarden dann
kommt dazu dass die Schuldenbremse die
sie angreifen wollen die schafft die
Möglichkeit in diesem Jahr 45 Milliarden
zusätzliche Schulden zu machen ja weil
sie klug ist weil sie eine Konj
45 jetzt ist sie klug ich find sie auch
klug und deswegen soll sie auch nicht
veränd B s ich auch gerne wenn ist
interessant da halten wir fest dass es
diese konjunkturkomponente gibt und
dennoch gibt es der klug ist kann klüger
werden kann noch klüger werden einig was
sie damit versuchen ist doch dass sie
noch mal zusätzliche Milliarden Schulden
aufnehmen und das ist das Fass ohne
Boden und das führt dann dazu dass wir
immer weitere Zinsen bezahlen im letzten
Jahr 3 Milliarden Zinsen im
Bundeshaushalt dieses Jahr 16 Milliarden
Zinsen im Bundeshaus nächstes Jahr 40
Milliarden Zinsen das macht die
Investitionsmöglichkeiten kaputt und das
ist das Ergebnis dieser Schuldenpolitik
so also Herr Dobrind sorry aber das geht
so nicht ich bin ja nicht
be bin ja nicht bei Dan B dass wir an
die grundgesetzliche Schuldenbremse ran
mussen müssen weil sie bereits klug ist
und genau die genannte Konjunktur
Komponente bereits enthält aber ich
verstehe gar nicht
war ich verstehe gar nicht genau warum
sie sich mit ihm streiten warum streiten
sie sich nicht mit dem regierenden
Bürgermeister von Berlin der von der CDU
gestellt wird der heute fordert die
Schuldenbremse aufzuweichen ich halte
das für falsch reden sie zuerst mit
ihren Parteifreunden ich bin wie gesagt
nicht der Auffassung dass wir an die
Schuldenbremse ran müssen aber weil sie
bereits klug ist aber so zu tun als ob
Ablenkung entschuldigung da gibt es
jetzt jetzt eine Einzelstimme in Berlin
und sie haben eine wo sie eine grünen
Koalitionspartner haben und einen SPD
Koalitionspartner haben die beide
öffentlich erklären sie wollen die
Schuldenbremse angreifen ich will darauf
hinweisen dass sie erst im eigenen Laden
vielleicht für Klarheit sorgenor
sie darüber ich wollte ganz kurz noch
mal Herr Bayers auf diesen ohon von
Robert habck kommen Robert habck gibt in
diesem Zitat Friedrich März der
Opposition die Schuld daran dass die
Bürger jetzt diese hohen Preise zu
zahlen haben für Gas und für Strom ist
das billig oder ist es eigentlich schon
dreist ich glaub der Robert habbeck
ärgert sich selbst über die Worte ich
kenne das wenn man morgens um 6 Uhr im
Deutschland Funken Interview gibt ja ja
habe ich letzte Woche auch gemacht guten
Morgen aber Spaß beiseite und zur
Ernsthaftigkeit ich kann das verstehen
dass der Bundeswirtschaftsminister es
umtreibt das wichtige Zukunftsprojekte
diese Industrie und noch einmal das sind
jetzt nicht spaßprojekte von
ihlich wichtige Projekte und es ist habe
ich ja schon vor zwei Antworten gesagt
das ist legitim im Rechtsstaat und
legitim in der Demokratie und sogar die
Aufgabe der OPOS i diese Rechte
wahrzunehmen und deswegen sagte ich ja
auch es wird der Regierung gut zu
Gesicht stehen einfach mal zu sagen
diese Strategie die wir aufgelegt haben
ist gescheitert und jetzt müssen wir
aber nach vorne gucken auch unsere
Schlüsse daraus ziehen und nach vorne
klüger werden das ist auch legitim und
insofern sollten wir darüber sprechen
wie wir genau dieses gewaltige Problem
vor dem wir stehen nämlich würde wie die
Ampel besser gesagt den Bundeshaushalt
24 der übrigens dann auch wiederum
Effekte auf die Länder hat weil wir
haben jetzt z.B auch ein wichtiges
wasserstoffprojekt bei uns in
badenwürttenberg von Automobil
Hersteller wo sich die Frage stellt
kommt das oder kommt das nicht dass wir
da möglichst schnell eine Lösung finden
wir sind uns einig dass der Brandstifter
versucht sich zu beschweren dass die
Feuerwehr gerufen ist und wenn sie sagen
das hat er aus Versehen gemacht dann sie
müssen mich nicht übersetzen
interpretieren meine Worte stehen für
sich und die hab wollte nur sagen dass
ich damit zufrieden bin
und das ist ein netter Austausch und das
gibt mir die Chance wenigstens genauso
nett nach Mainz zu schalten zu SAR Tacke
der Kollegin im ZDF die sich wie keine
zweite auskennt mit allen wichtigen
juristischen Fragen dieser
Nachtragshaushalt Sara und damit erstmal
einen guten Abend ähm das geht jetzt so
einfach durch oder wird der
Bundesfinanzminister damit noch
irgendein Problem haben Bundestag muss
ja
zustimmen also einfach ist aktuell gar
nichts muss man sagen aber es ist die
kleinste Herausforderung vor der die
Ampel aktuell steht denn der
Nachtragshaushalt der das laufende Jahr
2023 betrifft ist durch die neuen
Maßstäbe die das Verfassungsgericht
letzte Woche aufgestellt hat
verfassungsfedrich er eine Meinung unter
allen Verfassungsrechtlern ja kann aber
relativ leicht geheilt werden weil der
Maßstab ist oder die Vorgabe die aus
Karlsruhe da kam ist dass eine
Notsituation jedes Jahr wieder aufs Neue
festgestellt werden muss und das ist in
diesem Zusammenhang nicht so schwer denn
Herr Dobrind hatte es gerade ausgeführt
der im ukrainekrieg 2022 das ist eine
klassische Notsituation unvorhersehbares
Ereignis im Sinne der Schuldenbremse
eine Notsituation eine Ausnahmesituation
darauf musste man reagieren und hier
kommt wieder der neue mastab des
Verfassungsgerichts je länger die die
Ursache her ist desto höher sind die
Anforderungen jetzt zu begründen wieso
die Notsituation noch fortgedauert hat
Stichwort Energiekrise das sollte ab
aber der Krieg geht doch auch weiter ne
also der Krieg geht auch weiter wir
haben diese Verteidigungsausgaben zu
zahlen BürgerInnen und Unternehmen
fragen sich jetzt natürlich wiederum
zurück zu dem eigentlichen
Beruf und dem wichtigen Beritt den Sie
uns helfen aufzuklären s die fragen sich
was von den versprochenen Hilfen kriege
ich und was fällt gegebenenfalls Weg
einfache und gute Nachricht was
versprochen ist wird gezahlt sowohl an
die Bürger als auch an die Unternehmen
ähm ganz praktisch wenn ich eine Zusage
habe eine verbindliche Zusage dass eine
Wärmepumpe oder eine Hausdämmung oder
ein Elektroauto subventioniert wird dann
wird das auch gezahlt und das gleiche
gilt für Unternehmen in natürlich einer
anderen Dimension auch bei Milliarden
förder zu sagen da ist der Staat
gebunden Geld hat er zu haben wie er es
kriegt das ist das gegenwärtige Problem
aber nicht der das Problem der
BürgerInnen und der Unternehmen in dem
Fall interessant könnte es
schlimmstenfalls passieren dass man
Hilfen zurückzahlen muss dann
offensichtlich auch nicht auch da ein
ganz klares NEIN Hilfen die gezahlt
wurden müssen nicht zurückgezahlt werden
das Problem liegt in der Zukunft die
ampelregierung hat aktuell keine Antwort
darauf was Sie in Zukunft zahlen kann
das heißt ich weiß aktuell als Bürger
oder Unternehmer nicht welche und ob
überhaupt ich subention Subvention in
den nächsten Jahren bekommen das Problem
liegt in der Zukunft ja welche
Konsequenzen wird drohen wenn die Union
jetzt tatsächlich auch gegen den
Nachtragshaushalt und den folgenden noch
mal
klar also beim Nachtragshaushalt würde
ich die Chancen gering einschätzen wie
wenn die Ampel das jetzt sauber
begründet das ist machbar beim Haushalt
2024 das ja das Kernproblem vor dem die
Ampel steht da kommt ehrlich drauf an
wie der aussehen wird das kann ich nicht
prognostizieren weil gar nicht klar ist
wie der aussieht und was da jetzt
beschlossen wird in der Ampel welche und
das interessiert unsere Zuschauer auch
weil sie es tatsächlich auch gefragt
haben klug welche Konsequenzen hat es
eigentlich wenn eine Regierung ein so
vernichtendes Urteil aus aus Karlsruhe
hört gibt's da
Strafen Strafen gibt's nicht auch keine
strafzahlen das Verfassungsgericht lebt
davon dass die Urteile respektiert
werden und die Strafe ist im Grunde das
was wir gerade erleben dass Politik
dafür sorgen muss dass das Urteil
respektiert wird und dass die Vorgaben
eingehalten werden das heißt dass man
Nachtragshaushalt macht dass man Geld
besorgt das ist die Strafe vielleicht
Strafen die Wähler auch am Ende die
dafür ab dass ist Demokratie dass ein
Urteil des Verfassungsgerichts
respektiert wird und das Wirten ehrlich
gesagt ein ganz anderes Problem wenn
wenn Urteil des Verfassungsgerichts
nicht respektiert wden aber da sind wir
bei weitem nicht von daher spricht das
Verfassungsgericht durch seine Urteil
und braucht keine Strafen SAR letzte
Frage die Schuldenbremse hat
Verfassungsrang der Klimaschutz hat
genauso Verfassungsrang
interessanterweise zwei Jahre zuvor gab
es dieses wichtige Urteil das dazwischen
ist Politik und irgendwie leistbar oder
sagen auch sie am Ende wäre es klug
diese
Schuldenbremse neu zu formulieren damit
eben nicht in jedem Jahr diese
Transparenz hergestellt werden muss die
in einem so langen Prozess Klimaschutz
Transformation der gesamten Wirtschaft
wird wahrscheinlich 20 Jahre brauchen
immer wieder nachweisen zu müssen sagen
auch sie das muss vielleicht neu
formuliert werden oder sagen Sie das ist
jetzt schlicht Aufgabe der
Politik das ist schlicht Aufgabe der
Politik die Verfassungsrichter haben
auch nicht gesagt die Politik muss
sparen sie haben nur gesagt wenn Sie
eine Schuldenbremse ins Grundgesetz
schreiben dann müssen sich auch daran
halten und das gleiche gilt auch fürs
Klima das klimaurteil ist so zu
verstehen dass die Verfassungsrichter
gesagt haben Klimaschutz ist im
Grundgesetz verankert aufgrund der
Rechte der nachfolgenden Generation und
wenn Bundesregierung sich Klimaziele
setzt D muss sie auch dafür sorgen dass
die erreicht werden aber wie das gemacht
wird ob durch Schulden oder wie da sind
die Verfassungsrichter raus ähm was man
aber auch noch mal klar machen muss weil
das eben in der Runde auch durcheinander
ging was jetzt nicht geht ist ein
klimanotstand ausrufen also man kann die
Klimakrise ist eine Dauerkrise ist die
das Gegenteil von dem Einzelfall von was
unvorhersehbaren und was auch nicht geht
weil Herr dobr das gesagt hatte man man
kann jetzt auch nicht sagen die
Situation aktuell auch wenn sich die für
die handelnden Politiker anfühlen mag
wie eine Notsituation es ist keine
Notsituation weil sie selbstverschuldet
ist das heißt die Notsituation von der
wir im Grundgesetz sprechen ist eine von
außen herbeigeführte unvorhersehbare
Situation und die haben wir akell nicht
Krieg eine Katastrophe eine Pandemie
eine Pandemie das war ja tatsächlich der
Ausgang überhaupt darüber nachzudenken
Sarah Tacke ganz herzlichen Dank nach
Mainz auch für diese scharfen
aufklärenden Worte wir sind bei der
Frage her Dobrind in welche Richtung
tatsächlich das was sie bei der
Verteidigung bei den
Verteidigungsaufgaben Ausgaben möglich
gemacht haben nicht auch beim Klima
statt finden müsste müssten sie nicht
auch da sagen das ist eine so große eine
so wichtige Aufgabe die kann man nicht
irgendwie in einem in einer Legislatur
schaffen dafür werden wir ein paar
brauchen
und da sind wir als Opposition mit an
der Seite der Bundesregierung die Frage
ist doch erstmal was hat die
Bundesregierung jetzt für Ideen die 2024
die muss irgendwie mit einem Haushalt
gefüllt werden so und bisher wissen wir
nichts darüber wir wissen nur die Zahlen
auch wenn sie glaub das sei alles aus
inflationsbedingt das ist halt nicht
richtig aber man kann ja darüber
streiten ob diese Zahlen ausreichen aber
erstmal muss doch eine Regierung
erklären wie sie mit einem
riesenhaushalt wie sie mit einer
verschuldungsmöglichkeit die über die
Schuldenbremse möglich ist dann auch
ihre Aufgaben erledigt echt nur zu
erklären das brauchen wir für alles
andere und dann gibt's noch mal was ganz
wichtiges das können wir aber damit
einfach nicht finanzieren und deswegen
müssen wir da neue Regeln schaffen das
ist nicht Politik das ist einfach nur
sch machen g gleich ist er wieder dran
also ist ja die Antwort auch relativ
klar welche Dimension von Streit muss
man sich jetzt in diese Regierung
künftig vorstellen wenn wir uns ganz
kurz erinnern welche Auseinandersetzung
es um diese Kindergrundsicherung gegeben
hat also die Regierung wird jetzt gucken
müssen wo sie im Haushalt
2024 sparen kann wir haben im Sommer
gesehen wo es darum ging ein paar
Milliarden einzusparen
der Finanzminister den einzelnen
Ministerien sozusagen sagte ihr könnt
selber gucken wo ihr sparen wollt ähm
dann gab es diesen Streit um die
Kindergrundsicherung
äh wo ä nicht die Summe die sich die
Grünen vorgestellt haben möglich war äh
daraufhin hat die grüne
Familienministerin das
wachstumschancengesetz äh boyottiert und
das zeigt wie hart die Kämpfe werden ähm
ich wollte noch mal ein einen Aspekt
eröffnen diese Form also Klimaschutz ist
ein wichtiges Ziel auf das hat sich die
große Koalition vorher kommittet auf das
hat sich die Ampel auch kommittet
undgesetz Verfassungsrang richtig
und wir sehen jetzt was für einen
finanziellen Aufwand zumindest die Form
wie es die ampelmacht
erfordert wenn man es komplett über
Subventionen macht und es gibt vom Keler
weltwirtschaftsinstitut tut die haben
sich mal angeguckt wie sich die
Subventionen jedes Jahr entwickeln unter
der ampelregierung im Jahr
2023 wird von einem Euro den die
Bundesregierung ausgibt werden 30 Cent
gehen für Subventionen raus und da sagen
die Keler Wissenschaftler das sprengt
jeden bisherigen Rahmen das ist die
Frage ob Sie diesen Weg durchhalten kann
so massiv zu
subventionieren eine Möglichkeit
Klimaschutz zu finanzieren wäre
tatsächlich ein Sondervermögen zu
schaffen so wie es für die Bundeswehr
geschaffen worden ist ein Sondervermögen
Klimaschutz dafür wird die Union
gebraucht weil es eine
Grundgesetzänderung Bedarf die Union
schon den Kopf dann muss man sich fragen
mus doch einsparungel gesag Klimaschutz
Herr bayas hat es auch gerade vorhin
gesagt auf ein ganz anderes Konzept
stellt also ihre Kollegin im
Sachverständigen Rat Veronika Grimm hat
vorgeschlagen die CO2 Preise auszu
weiten und dann aber die Einnahmen an
die Bürger zurückzahlen Stichwort
klimageld
sowas ähnliches hat die FDP tatsächlich
auf ihrem Bundesparteitag beschlossen
das hat aber dann der FDP Parteichef
Christian Lindner einkassiert ich bin da
auch sehr dafür das Problem ist in der
politischen Praxis wenn der Wind mal ein
bisschen von vorne bläst wie im letzten
Jahr dann ist das ausgesetzt worden mein
Ministerpräsident erzählt mir gerne die
Anekdote wie er den alten Finanzminister
Bundesfinanzminister Olaf Scholz
überzeugen musste mit den Länderkollegen
von lächerlichen 10 € was keine
Lenkungswirkung hat überhaupt mal bei 25
einzusteigen für
diechaft alle sofort dabei und in der
politischen Praxis muss man es dann halt
auch z ich bin da auch sehr dafür und
ich bin auch für das klimageld aber da
müssen wir auch alle an einem Strang
ziehen und nicht beim ersten Mal wenn
der Wind wieder ein bisschen von vorne
bläst Horrorszenarien von der 80 kilomet
pendelen Krankenschwestern mit SUV die
sich das nicht mehr bezahlen kann weil
das ist so manchmal das niau der DEB
find diesen Appell sehr richtig zu sagen
dass aus den Parteien der Mitte ein
gemeinsames Konzept und nicht nur der
ampelparteien auch mit der i der CDU
zusammen aus der aus den Parteien der
Mitte kommen sollte weil im nächsten
Bundestag
2025 bin ich mir nicht mehr so sicher ob
die Parteien der Mitte noch eine zwei
Drittel Mehrheit hinbekommen um das
Grundgesetz eventuell erstm sag also
Steuererhöhungen sind keine Lösung
erstens hochsteuerland zweitens erleben
wir schon dauernd Steuererhöhungen
erbschaftssteuererhöht worden Gast
Steuer das ist einfach falsch was gerade
er nicht
falch die ABA erhöhttung
tungsundlage diewertunggrundlage hat
diese Koalition mit Christian Lindner
erhöht
steueres
chuldigung aber m die
real
nachprüfen Co Bepreisung da haben wir
mal klimageld sie versprochen das kommt
bis heute nicht bei den Menschen an das
ist natürlich nichts anderes als
letztlich dann auch eine Steuererhöhung
so und deswegen müssen wir erstens über
sparen reden und dann kann man doch mal
anfangen was ist denn mit dem heizgesetz
das kostet jetzt ab nächstes Jahr
Milliarden bringt aber beim Klimaschutz
relativ wenig kann man doch machen bei
der kindergrundsicher 5000 gesagt sie
sagten ja es ist eigentlich nicht ihre
Aufgabe jetzt zu sagen wo man sparen ms
kommt nicht jetzt muss mal Anreize
setzen und sagen was wie gehen wir die
EEG Umlage wurde gesenkt was m
erichterung
genau mit dem
heizgesetz richtig und ab 27 muss es
sowieso gelten ich glaube wir tun uns
jetzt keinen großen Gefallen wenn wir
einzelne Positionen dieses Haushaltes
durchgehen weil man priorisieren muss
und dann sagt man nicht was gut oder
schlecht ist sondern man sagt was ist
besser und wichtiger als das and
ich finde interessant noch mal zu fragen
wie groß eigentlich die Gefahr ist
dass sie relativ schnell Herr dobr
aufgefordert sind in eine Regierung
einzutreten dann stünden sie nämlich
plötzlich selber vor dem Problem es gibt
nicht wenige die das schon an die Wand
mal dass es bald geschieht lassen Sie
uns das zusammen machen und wenn sie es
mit den Grünen nicht hinbekommen dann
werfen Sie sie raus dann machen wir es
mit ihnen schwarzgrün ist derzeit ein
Auslaufmodell rot ist attraktiver weil
gerade in Krisenzeiten der gesunde
Menschenverstand stärker im Mittelpunkt
steht und nicht die ideologischen Ideen
wie bei den
Grünen so Herr lieber gar nicht regieren
als ohne Geld regieren müssen sie
befürchten dieser Ruf nach der großen
Koalition von H ist ja spannend also ich
denke an die coronazeit war Friedrich
Merz friich mer und dannö entschuldig
Herr Söder Herr Seehofer
sorry ja genau Herr Söder ist ja
spannend wenn ich noch an die coronazeit
denke der erändnert sich jeder mit Graus
übrigens auch an die Schulden damals die
Haushalte waren wesentlich
katastrophaler und größer er sie haben
basisabstimmung bei sich in der Partei
das das am Rande diese Koalition nein
diese Koalition ich will das Sagen
Freund diese Koalition hat die Aufgabe
sich dieser Verantwortung zu stellen wir
haben eine Staatspraxis gehabt in der
Vergangenheit beim Thema
Nettokreditaufnahme die wird jetzt
geändert das werden wir gemeinsam tun
und wir haben die Aufgabe Prioritäten zu
setzen und desweg haben eine
basisabstimmung ihr ja komme ich komme
ich sofort drauf wie ernst müssen Sie
die nehmen wir wir nehmen das wir nehmen
alles immer sehr ernst das ist sogar
keine Frage aber es ist eine Dimension
wenn ich weiß dass auch bei den Grünen
einige Briefe schreiben derzeit wir
haben eine Satzung in der FDP die eine
Besonderheit hat schon ab 500 geht eine
Mitgliederbefragung los und das ist auch
absolut legitim die Stimme die ich höre
von der breiten Basis ist dass die FDP
sich richtigerweise der Verantwortung
gestellt hat 2021 und sie jetzt
natürlich auch weitertragen sollte und
das werden wir tun und des deswegen mein
letzter Punkt Frau ilner gerade weil
hier der Eindruck entsteht es sei kein
Geld mehr da der Staat hat Geld er muss
jetzt priorisieren und lassen Sie uns
beim Klimaschutz doch eins tun einfach
eine klügere Politik machen und das hat
das Bundeskabinett gestern Abend
getanndkab BU msen mit weniger Geld eine
klügere Politik ma genauso ist es und
ich will ein Beispiel nennen wie wir
bereits gestern entschieden haben wir
haben in Deutschland im gegen dem Verbot
der großen Koalition nach demem nach der
jetzt Herr Söder ruft wir haben entgegen
des Verbots der großen Koalition ab
sofort synthetische Kraftstoffe
zugelassen Übens auch ferung des
badenwürtenbergischen Verkehrsministers
wenn ich es richtig sehe also mehr
technologieoffenheit eine andere neue
Energiepolitik nicht die ganze Zeit
schon macht ich will noch mal nach der
politischen Zukunft diese Ampel Fragen
Frau russenfeld wie Knopf auf wie sagt
man knopfum sicherer Zugriff zu
verstehenen Redewendung wie spitz auf
Knopf steht es eigentlich vergleiche ich
die Ampel immer gerne mit dem Lied der
Eagles Hotel California you can check
out anytime you like but you can never
leave also man ist eineeinander gekettet
weil wenn man sich allein die Umfrage
Werte anschaut jetzt die Koalition
platzen zu lassen und als gescheiterte
in einen Wahlkampf zu gehen kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen vielleicht erlebt die
Ampel ihren Gerhard Schröder Moment also
es war eine rotgrüne Koalition die mit
dem Rücken an der Wand stand die
wirtschaftlichen Umstände waren
dramatisch und man hat die Kraft
gefunden eine Reform zu machen die nicht
Parteiinteressen sondern tatsächlich den
Interessen des Landes gedient hat die
Frage ist eine politische und ich gebe
sie doch mal an die Ökonomen Frau
Schnitzer auch bei den Grünen da gibt's
jetzt gerade den Parteitag die haben
noch keine
Unterschriftenaktion aber auch da biegen
sich ja verändern oder besser gesagt
müssen werden gezwungen auch aus
Koalitionen rauszugehen die Grünen in
dieser jetzigen politischen Situation
sehr
werden die Grünen sich selber aus dem
Spiel nehmen glauben sie oder halten die
durch sie
dieses ich glaube hier müssen sich
einfach alle bewegen ich glaube die
Grünen haben sich schon sehr bewegt ich
glaube die FDP hat sich bisher noch
nicht ganz so doll bewegt weil es ja
immer darum ging kann man auch mal
Einnahmen erhöhen bei wem wird gekürzt
kann man die Schuldenbremse noch mal mit
einer Ausnahmeregel ziehen da war man ja
bisher sehr Star und ich glaube in
dieser Situation schätzens es am Ende
die Wählerinnen und Wähler wenn man
sieht in schwierigen Zeiten springt man
auch mal über seinen Schatten ich glaube
die sind so intelligent dass sie
verstehen die Zeiten sind schwierig und
da muss sich jeder bewegen so Herr
dobren sie müssen jetzt noch mal sagen
glauben sie das auch oder läuft sich
Friedrich merärz schon
warm wirben wir erleben ja die letzten
Monate dass die Erfolglosigkeit kettet
diese
ampelkoalitionspartner aneinander und
das wird jetzt kein Millimeter besser
und ich sehe noch nicht dass der
Haushaltsstreit 2024 in dieser Ampel zu
lösen ist ob das dann dazu führt dass
diese Ampel nicht weiter regieren kann
und Neuwahlen anstehen das kann man aus
heutiger Zeit noch nicht sagen aber ich
glaube vorbereiten muss man sich bei
denen
auf so ziemlich alles und wir bereiten
uns draufor wir haben Angebote gemacht
zur Unterstützung das dar GL dies
Haushalt Herr ja ich aber das ist ja
immer so dass man mit den
Schwierigkeiten umgehen muss die andere
nicht mehr lösen kann das ist der
Wesenskern der Politik und dass die das
nicht mehr lösen können das müssen wir
dann auch machen und deswegen würde ich
mal sagen wir erwarten jetzt was 2024
oder mit 2024 passiert
wir haben unsere Unterstützung angeboten
aber das geht natürlich dann auch nur
wenn die Position und die Politik sich
an der Stelle Verkehrsminister Wissing
muss jetzt insgesamt 40 Milliarden in
die Deutsche Bahn investieren warum sind
das 40 Milliarden vielleicht auch
deshalb weil es vorher einen
Verkehrsminister Dobrind und einen
Verkehrsminister schuer gegeben hat P
muss auch in eine man muss auch in eine
Bahn immer wieder investieren auch in
der Vergangenheit ist investiert worden
möglicherweise ist auch über lange Zeit
zu wenig investiert worden da kann man
durchaus mehr machen aber ein System das
auf Kante wirklich auf Kante geschnitten
ist Daal als erstes 2 Milliarden
rauszunehmen das hat auf jeden Fall
nicht zur Verbesserung geführt und das
war das was als allererstes gemacht
worden ist von dieser Koalition Frau
Schnitzer auch da noch mal man kann den
Spieß auch umdrehen wie sehr hat Angela
Merkel dieser jetzigen ampelregierung
ein einen schlechten Zustand in der
Infrastruktur des Landes hinter lassen
Stichwort Energiesituation Abhängigkeit
von Russland Atomausstieg Flüchtlinge
Bahn
Digitalisierung war das Land in einem
schlechten Zustand nach 16 Jahren Angela
Merkel also tatsächlich hat man zu wenig
in Infrastruktur man hat zu wenig in
Digitalisierung investiert man hat die
energieewende nicht gut genug
vorbereitet aber da haben dann auch
andere behindert den Stromtrassen vom
Norden in den Süden die hätten fertig
sein sollen zum atomaus s da hat z.B
Bayern lange dagegen gearbeitet an der
Stelle also ist
einigesung jetzt fangen die Bauarbeiten
im Norden an also was für
Norden do nicht
BoF
Monster jetzt mal fragen warum den die
Kernenergie abgeschalten worden ist
Kernenergie
abschalten wollte gerade sagen daen mit
K hätte man jetzt verlängern können wenn
die großeeriekrise ist braucht noch viel
Ehrlichkeit nicht nur in dieser sindung
sondern auch in der Politik und vor
allen Dingen in der Regierung ich darf
mich ganz herzlich bedanken für die
Diskussion hier heute Abend und Verweise
sie sie natürlich an Markus Lanz der
unter anderem Herrn eibanger zu Gast hat
wir sehen uns wenn Sie mögen und können
nächsten Donnerstag wieder gleiche
Stelle gleiche Welle kommen Sie gut
durch diese Nacht und durch die Tage bye
bye vielen Dank tschüss danke
[Musik]
schön